Narrator:
TONIGHT, SILICON VALLEY
BILLIONAIRE CHRIS SACCA
JOINS THE SHARKS.
Narrator:
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
Lavanya: WE'RE HUGE NERDS,
AND WE ARE NERDS
THAT WANT TO SHARE THAT PASSION
WITH OTHER STUDENTS.
WHICH ONE OF YOU IS READY
TO INVEST LIKE A CHAMPION?
IF THE SHARKS HEAR A GREAT IDEA
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I LOVE THE PRODUCT.
ODD PEOPLE MAKE GREAT THINGS.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
WE'D LOVE TO WORK
WITH BOTH OF YOU.
I'M WILLING TO SHARE.
YOU'RE WILLING TO SHARE BECAUSE
YOU'RE SWIMMING IN MY WAKE.
OH, WOW.
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
-WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
-ZERO!
I CAN'T TELL WHETHER YOU'RE
PITCHING OR ASKING FOR THERAPY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
AS VENTURE DEBT.
WE WOULD LOVE
TO CONSIDER IT.
YOU'RE LOOKING A GIFT HORSE
RIGHT IN THE MOUTH.
I'M NOT GONNA SCREW THIS UP,
MARK.
I CAME IN HERE WITH A VALUATION
THAT I BELIEVED WAS FAIR.
DO YOU THINK MONEY'S FREE?
DO YOU THINK I JUST GIVE IT AWAY
'CAUSE I DON'T CARE ABOUT IT?
-SO, WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
[ SLIDE WHISTLE BLOWS ]
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND BILLIONAIRE INVESTOR
CHRIS SACCA
LEFT HIS HIGH-PROFILE POSITION
AT GOOGLE
AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS CAREER
TO START HIS OWN
VENTURE-CAPITAL FUND,
WHICH IS NOW
ONE OF THE HIGHEST PERFORMING
INVESTMENT FUNDS IN HISTORY
WITH EARLY INVESTMENTS
IN TWITTER, INSTAGRAM, AND UBER.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A WAY TO OPTIMIZE
THE EXPERIENCE OF ROOTING
FOR YOUR HOME TEAM.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MIKE DOYLE,
AND I'M THE C.E.O.
OF RENT LIKE A CHAMPION.
AND I'M DREW MITCHELL,
THE CO-FOUNDER
OF RENT LIKE A CHAMPION.
SHARKS, WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO ASK YOU FOR $200,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF OUR BUSINESS.
IMAGINE A CRISP FALL
FOOTBALL WEEKEND.
YOU'RE BACK AT YOUR ALMA MATTER
WITH YOUR FAMILY
AND YOUR TEAM JUST WON
BY A TOUCHDOWN.
WHOO!
YOU'RE RIDING HIGH
AND BASKING IN THE TRADITION.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO PILE
THE KIDS INTO THE CAR,
FIGHT TWO HOURS OF TRAFFIC
TO DRIVE THE 15 MILES
BACK TO THE HOTEL
WHERE THE GROUP SPLITS UP
INTO THREE SEPARATE HOTEL ROOMS.
JUST LIKE THAT, YOUR FAMILY'S
GAME-DAY EXPERIENCE IS OVER.
[ SLIDE WHISTLE BLOWS ]
SHARKS...
-[ CHUCKLES ] STRONG.
-...NOT ANYMORE.
THANKS TO
RENT LIKE A CHAMPION,
WE SOLVED THAT PROBLEM
BY CONNECTING FANS
WITH THEIR OWN HOME
JUST STEPS FROM THE STADIUM.
LAST YEAR,
49 MILLION AMERICANS ATTENDED
A COLLEGE FOOTBALL GAME.
AND AN ESTIMATED
70% OF THOSE
NEED A PLACE TO STAY.
FANS LIKE THOSE
FLOCK TO OUR WEBSITE,
CHOOSE THE TOWN AND THE EVENT
THAT THEY'RE ATTENDING,
AND BOOK A WEEKEND RENTAL
MATCHING THEIR PRECISE CRITERIA.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
EASY PROCESS.
AND SHARKS,
IT'S THE FOURTH QUARTER,
AND WE'RE READY
TO OFFER ONE OF YOU THE BALL.
NOW, WHICH ONE OF YOU IS READY
TO INVEST LIKE A CHAMPION?
WHAT'S THE BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOU AND AIRBNB?
THE BIG DIFFERENCE --
WE FOCUS ON BIG EVENTS.
I CAN'T GO TO AIRBNB
AND RENT DURING A BIG EVENT?
YOU COULD.
YOU KNOW WHAT, PROBABLY NOT
IN SOUTH BEND, INDIANA,
-OR IN ANN ARBOR.
-WHY?
YOU'RE NOT GONNA FIND
THE INVENTORY THAT WE HAVE.
-BUT YOU ARE?
-WE'RE OPERATING
IN NON-TRADITIONAL
VACATION-RENTAL MARKETS,
SO WE'RE FINDING
THESE SMALL TOWNS
WHERE PEOPLE
AREN'T DOING THIS.
Herjavec: TELL ME
HOW YOU FIND THOSE HOMES
AND WHY THOSE PEOPLE WOULDN'T GO
TO AIRBNB AND THEY GO TO YOU.
SO, ON THE HOMEOWNER SIDE --
AGAIN, THIS IS A MARKETPLACE
THAT REALLY DOESN'T EXIST
IN THESE TOWNS,
SO THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
THIS IS AN OPTION.
HOW DO YOU EDUCATE?
Doyle: SO, WE USE
DIGITAL MARKETING
TO TARGET THE EXACT ZIP CODES
NEAR THE STADIUM.
ONCE WE HAVE
AT LEAST 50 PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN LISTING
ON OUR SITE,
WE SEND ONE OF OUR TEAM MEMBERS
DOWN TO THESE TOWNS.
WE MEET WITH THEM
IN PERSON,
JUST LIKE A COACH
IN THE LIVING ROOM,
AND WE RECRUIT THEM
TO COME ON TO OUR SITE.
OH, WOW. SO, YOU'RE, LIKE --
YOU'RE IN THERE ONE BY ONE.
Sacca: I GOT TO BE HONEST,
IF I'M RENTING MY HOUSE OUT,
I'VE GOT MY FINGERS CROSSED THAT
FOOTBALL FANS DON'T RENT IT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THEY'RE THERE FOR THE GAME.
THEIR TRASHED.
THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT WE'VE DEFINITELY HEARD.
WELL, BOTTOM LINE FOR ME,
EXACTLY BECAUSE OF WHAT
CHRIS SAID, I'M OUT.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS KIND OF
THE SIZE OF THIS MARKET
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SO FAR.
SO, LAST YEAR,
COLLEGE FOOTBALL FANS
SPENT $12 BILLION
SUPPORTING THEIR TEAMS.
OF THAT, $2.5 BILLION
WENT TOWARDS LODGING.
WE'VE PROCESSED
THROUGH OUR PLATFORM
$6.1 MILLION
WORTH OF RENTALS.
THAT HAS EARNED US
$1.4 MILLION IN FEES.
THAT'S VERY RESPECTABLE.
-WOW, MIKE, THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-WHAT ABOUT THIS TRASHING ISSUE?
-I WASN'T EXPECTING THAT.
SURE.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF OWNERS SAY,
"MY HOUSE GOT TRASHED.
EVERYTHING IN IT'S DESTROYED
AND EVERYBODY THREW UP
IN MY KITCHEN"?
CHRIS, I DID WANT TO TOUCH
ON THAT.
I WASN'T TRYING TO AVOID
THE SUBJECT.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THEY LEAVE IT IN PERFECT SHAPE
WITH A ROSE ON THE TABLE.
SO, WE HAVE PROCESSED
NEARLY 4,000 RENTALS
IN THE LIFETIME
OF THE COMPANY.
IN THOSE RENTALS,
THE INCIDENT RATE HAS BEEN 1.9%.
WHEN THERE IS AN INCIDENT,
THE AVERAGE CHARGE TO
SECURITY DEPOSIT HAS BEEN $98.
Sacca:
LET ME GIVE YOU A QUICK STORY.
I MET THE AIRBNB GUYS
IN THE FIRST FEW DAYS
OF THEIR COMPANY,
AND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO INVEST IN THAT COMPANY
AT JUST A FEW MILLION DOLLARS
VALUATION.
AND I ACTUALLY LET
THE NEGATIVE CASE CLOUD MY VIEW.
I LITERALLY WAS LIKE,
"SOMEBODY'S GONNA GET MURDERED
AND THE BLOOD
IS GONNA BE ON YOUR HANDS."
AND THAT COST ME
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS,
MAYBE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT SAID,
IF THIS IS THAT BIG A MARKET,
YOU MUST HAVE COME UP
AGAINST THEM COMPETITIVELY.
ARE YOU SEEING THEM START
TO TARGET THIS SAME AUDIENCE?
NOT YET.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE REALLY
RIGHT NOW FOCUSED ON BIG CITIES.
AS DREW SAID, IF YOU'RE GOING
TO TUSCALOOSA, ALABAMA,
OR STATE COLLEGE, PENNSYLVANIA,
OR AUBURN, ALABAMA,
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE A TON
OF INVENTORY IN THESE TOWNS.
AND THE GREAT THING
ABOUT THIS PROBLEM WE'RE SOLVING
IS IT'S A PROBLEM
ON BOTH SIDES.
SO, WE'RE GETTING FEES FROM THE
HOMEOWNER AND FROM THE RENTER.
AND WHAT DO YOU CHARGE
THE HOMEOWNER?
THE RENTER?
THERE'S A 15% FEE
ON THE HOMEOWNER'S SIDE,
AND THERE'S AN 8% FEE
ON THE RENTER'S SIDE.
SO, WE'RE BUTTERING
BOTH SIDES OF THE BREAD.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT FOLKS THAT WE'RE SOLVING
THE PROBLEMS FOR,
THEY'RE KIDS
AND THEY'RE FAMILIES
AND IT'S AUNTS AND UNCLES
AND GRANDMA AND GRANDPA.
THEY'RE COMING BACK
TO THE CAMPUS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO STAY
IN MULTIPLE HOTEL ROOMS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA
AND THEIR KIDS
ARE DOWN THE HALL
AND THEY DON'T GET TO PINCH
THE CHEEKS.
WE PUT THEM IN A HOME.
IT'S A WAY BETTER EXPERIENCE.
SLOW DOWN. I'M WORRIED YOU'RE
GONNA SPONTANEOUSLY COMBUST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'VE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED
THE SOUTH BEND THING.
-I WENT TO A GAME LAST FALL.
-YEAH.
AND ALL THIS PASSION,
I SAW IT.
I ALSO HAD A HARD TIME
GETTING ENOUGH ROOMS
FOR ALL THE GUYS
I WENT DOWN WITH.
SURE.
HOW MANY LISTINGS
DO YOU HAVE IN SOUTH BEND?
SOUTH BEND
IS OUR BIGGEST MARKET.
WE'VE BEEN THERE
THE LONGEST.
WE HAVE 350 HOMES AVAILABLE
IN SOUTH BEND.
FOR BIG GAMES, WE'LL RENT OUT
80% TO 90% OF THOSE PROPERTIES.
TALK ABOUT THE GROWTH
IN THOSE LISTINGS.
SO, LAST YEAR, WE HAD ABOUT 200
HOMES IN SOUTH BEND.
THE REALLY COOL THING
ON THE HOMEOWNER'S SIDE
IS THAT PEOPLE START
TELLING THEIR FRIENDS
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY MADE,
THEY'RE BRAGGING
TO THEIR CO-WORKERS,
AND WE'RE GETTING REFERRALS
LEFT AND RIGHT.
OUR BEST HOMEOWNER
IN SOUTH BEND LAST YEAR
HAS TWO HOMES NEAR CAMPUS.
HE PULLED IN $40,000
USING OUR WEBSITE.
WOW.
FROM HIM ALONE, WE'VE RECEIVED
DOZENS OF REFERRALS.
AND HAVE YOU RAISED
ANY MONEY?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
DREW, HOW MUCH DEBT
DO WE HAVE ON THE COMPANY?
ZERO!
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE RAISED
OUTSIDE FUNDS?
ZERO!
THIS HAS BEEN
TOTALLY BOOTSTRAPPED, GUYS.
WE'RE HAVING FUN
AND WE'RE MAKING MONEY.
AND MIKE, SALES THIS YEAR
ARE $1.4 MILLION.
WHAT WILL THEY BE NEXT YEAR?
WHAT ARE YOU PROJECTING?
SO, THAT WAS --
THE $1.4 MILLION IN FEES,
THAT WAS LIFETIME, OKAY?
SO, IN 2014, OUR SALES THROUGH
THE PLATFORM WERE $2.3 MILLION.
WE KEPT $530,000 OF THAT
IN OUR FEES.
OKAY.
IN 2015, WE'LL PROCESS
$4.13 MILLION IN TRANSACTIONS.
THAT WILL NET US $950,000
IN OUR FEES.
YOU'RE NOT WORRIED
THAT AIRBNB SAYS, "LOOK --"
THEY JUST PUT
A SEPARATE TAB.
THEY'RE SAYING IF YOU'RE GOING
TO A COLLEGE GAME,
THIS IS THE PLACE
TO CHECK BECAUSE --
NO, AND HERE'S WHY.
BECAUSE THESE HOMES
ARE HARD TO SIGN UP.
YOU HAVE TO GO IN --
IN THESE TOWNS WHERE THEY'VE
NEVER HEARD OF THIS CONCEPT...
-I BUY IT, I BUY IT.
-...THE SHARING ECONOMY --
HOW MANY TOWNS ARE THERE
THAT ARE EVEN CLOSE
TO WHAT SOUTH BEND IS
IN TERMS OF RABID DEMAND?
THERE ARE 43 COLLEGE TOWNS
WHERE THEY AVERAGE
50,000 OR MORE PEOPLE PER GAME
IN ATTENDANCE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN 20.
WE'RE ASKING
FOR THE $200,000 INVESTMENT
TO GET INTO THE REMAINING 20
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
IN THE NEXT 12 MONTHS.
HOW DO YOU SPEND THE MONEY?
I GIVE YOU THE $200,000 --
SO, WE SPEND THE MONEY
ON DIRECT MAIL ADVERTISING,
AND THEN WE COUPLE THAT
SOMETIMES WITH RADIO ADS.
O'Leary:
LISTEN, I LIKE IT.
I'LL DO 200K FOR, UH, 15%
JUST 'CAUSE I LIKE TO NEGOTIATE.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, I MEAN, I WOULD DO 200K
FOR THE 10%.
YES!
I THINK IT'S A NO-BRAINER
AT THIS VALUATION.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?
THIS GUY'S GOT A BIG-TIME MAN
CRUSH ON YOU, BY THE WAY, SACCA.
I WAS DOING A LITTLE RESEARCH
LAST NIGHT.
[ Laughing ]
MAN CRUSHES LATELY.
-IT MUST BE THE BEARD.
-IT MUST BE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT,
I AM NOT OPPOSED TO LISTENING
TO WHAT THIS GUY MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO IF HE'S INTERESTED AT ALL.
I DO THINK HE HAS SOMETHING
TO BRING TO THE TABLE.
I LIKE IT. LOOK, I DON'T WANT
TO COMPETE WITH AIRBNB HEAD ON.
SURE.
BUT I DO THINK
THERE IS SOMETHING TO ADDRESSING
AN AUDIENCE THAT THOSE GUYS
HAVEN'T NECESSARILY GONE AFTER.
IF YOU WANT TO DO
SOMETHING TOGETHER
-AND JUST SPLIT IT, I'LL DO IT.
-YEAH.
YOU KNOW, REAL QUICK,
I WANT PEOPLE TO HELP --
YOU KNOW,
TO UNDERSTAND THE VISION.
MIKE'S TASKED RIGHT NOW --
YOU'RE LOOKING A GIFT HORSE
RIGHT IN THE MOUTH, RIGHT?
I'M NOT GONNA SCREW THIS UP,
MARK. I PROMISE YOU.
I JUST WANT EVERYBODY
TO UNDERSTAND --
JUST BE CAREFUL.
YOU LOOK A GIFT HORSE
IN THE MOUTH,
YOU MIGHT GET YOUR NOSE
BIT OFF.
HEY, I'LL SHUT IT UP.
WHEN I GET ADVICE LIKE THAT,
I KNOW WHEN TO STOP TALKING.
SO, WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
SO, 10% TOTAL FOR 200K?
CORRECT.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
-ALL RIGHT, WE GOT A PROVISION.
-GO NUTS.
WE'RE GONNA NEED BOTH YOU GUYS
TO COME TAILGATE WITH US.
-SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
-OKAY.
-AND THEN WE GOT A DEAL.
-AND I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
HE'S GOING.
I AIN'T GOING.
YOU KIDDING ME?
I WENT TO INDIANA.
I HATE NOTRE DAME.
I THINK THE DEAL'S OFF.
WE'LL DOUBLE IT
WITH AN INDIANA BASKETBALL GAME.
I WOULD GET BACK
TO THE DEAL.
ALL RIGHT, WE WOULD LOVE
TO DO THE DEAL WITH YOU GUYS.
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, GUYS.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THIS IS EXCITING FOR US.
YEAH, DREAM COME TRUE.
ALL RIGHT!
THANK YOU GUYS, BOTH,
VERY MUCH.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-CONGRATS, GUYS.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-I APPRECIATE IT, MAN.
-THANKS, MARK.
-THANKS, GUYS.
-THANK YOU, GUYS.
-YEAH, GREAT PITCH.
ALL RIGHT! YEAH!
OH, MAN!
TOUCHDOWN!
GOOD WORK.
Doyle: THIS IS EXACTLY
WHO WE WANTED TO DEAL WITH.
YOU KNOW, MARK HAS GOT
THE SPORTS WORLD COVERED.
EVERYTHING CHRIS TOUCHES
IN SILICON VALLEY TURNS TO GOLD.
I COULDN'T BE HAPPIER
WITH THE WAY THIS TURNED OUT.
CAN YOU GROW IT
BEYOND THAT
SO IT'S A TRUE COMPETITOR
TO AIRBNB?
WELL, I DON'T THINK SO.
I-I THINK IT'S A PICKUP
BY AIRBNB.
I THINK
IT'S THE KIND OF THING
THAT GETS ACQUIRED
BY THOSE GUYS.
WELL, YOU GOT TO PUT
PRESSURE ON THEM, YEAH.
AND LOOK, AT THAT VALUATION
WITH THAT KIND OF CASH FLOW
RIGHT NOW...
THERE'S NO DOWNSIDE.
...I THINK YOU CAN ONLY WIN
IN THAT DEAL.
MY NAME IS DANNY GROSSFELD
AND I'M FROM BAYSIDE, NEW YORK.
I GREW UP
IN A FAMILY OF ENTREPRENEURS.
MY FATHER RUNS A SUCCESSFUL
BANKRUPTCY AND LIQUIDATION
BUSINESS,
AND HE TAUGHT ME
EVERYTHING THAT I KNOW.
LISTEN, I NEED HELP
SELLING THIS STUFF.
THE KEY TO MY DAD'S HEART
IS BUSINESS.
YOU MAKE A SALE
AND HE'LL LOVE YOU FOREVER.
A FEW YEARS AGO, I WENT TO JAPAN
ON A BUSINESS TRIP,
AND I CAME ACROSS
THIS AMAZING PRODUCT
WHICH I ABSOLUTELY
FELL IN LOVE WITH.
AS SOON AS I GOT HOME,
I DID MY RESEARCH
AND I FOUND OUT THAT IT'S
A $15 BILLION A YEAR BUSINESS,
AND MOST PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER HEARD OF IT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH YOUR FUTURE?
[ SCOFFS ]
WHY DON'T YOU JUST GET
A RICH GIRL?
THIS PRODUCT
MEANS EVERYTHING TO ME.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME
THAT I EVER CREATED ANYTHING
FROM SCRATCH,
AND I WANT TO MAKE
MY FATHER PROUD.
I'VE TAKEN IT
AS FAR AS I CAN ON MY OWN.
WITH A SHARK ON MY SIDE, I THINK
WE CAN GROW THIS BUSINESS
TO BE AS BIG AS IT IS IN JAPAN.
THIS PRODUCT IS HOT,
AND THE SHARKS
ARE GONNA LOVE IT.
♪♪
HELLO,
MY NAME IS DANNY GROSSFELD,
AND I'M THE OWNER AND FOUNDER
OF HotShot.
I'M SEEKING $300,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
HotShot IS THE ULTIMATE
CONVENIENCE IN HOT COFFEE.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALL IN A RUSH
IN THE MORNING,
AND WE CAN'T START OUR DAY
WITHOUT COFFEE.
THERE'S NO CHANCE YOU'RE GONNA
GET WHERE YOU NEED TO BE
ON TIME AND FULLY CAFFEINATED.
SO, STOP ALL THE RUSHING,
'CAUSE YOU'RE NEVER GONNA HAVE
TO MAKE ANOTHER CUP OF COFFEE
OR WAIT IN LINE EVER AGAIN.
HotShot IS THE FIRST
GRAB-AND-GO, READY-TO-DRINK
HOT COFFEE IN A CAN.
THE MAGIC HAPPENS
WITH OUR HotBox.
IT'S A HOT FRIDGE
THAT HEATS AND STORES
HotShot CANS AT 140 DEGREES
24 HOURS A DAY, 7 DAYS A WEEK.
YOU JUST OPEN THE HotBox,
YOU REACH IN,
AND YOU GET A PERFECTLY PREPARED
HOT COFFEE
THAT'S READY TO DRINK
WHEN YOU ARE.
SO, JOIN THE COFFEE REVOLUTION
AND BECOME A HotShot.
GOT TO TRY IT.
BRING IT ON.
ABSOLUTELY.
LORI, WHAT KIND
DO YOU WANT?
THE CHOCOLATE.
OR THE FRENCH VANILLA.
EITHER.
ALL RIGHT,
THERE YOU GO.
OOH, IT'S WARM.
YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
AT 140 DEGREES.
REALLY?
ACTUALLY, YOU SHOULD FEEL
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE
WITHOUT AN INSULATED LABEL.
YOU CAN'T HOLD THE CAN
AT ALL.
OH, THE LABEL'S INSULATED.
ALL RIGHT, CHEERS,
EVERYBODY.
-IT'S OKAY.
-OOH, THAT'S PIPING HOT.
OH, THIS IS GOOD.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
DANNY, HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH IT?
THIS IS ACTUALLY MODELED AFTER
A CONCEPT THAT COMES FROM JAPAN.
I WAS IN JAPAN,
AND I HAD JET LAG.
I'M ROAMING THE STREETS OF TOKYO
5:00 IN THE MORNING
DESPERATE FOR A CUP OF COFFEE.
AND I KEEP WALKING INTO
CONVENIENCE STORE
AFTER CONVENIENCE STORE
AND I COULDN'T FIND
ONE POT OF COFFEE.
SO, ABOUT, LIKE,
THE FIFTH OR SIXTH STORE
I GOT FRUSTRATED.
I SAID, "I'M JUST GONNA GET
AN ICED COFFEE."
AND I WALKED
TO THE BACK OF THE STORE
TO WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS A REFRIGERATOR,
I REACH IN,
AND ALL THE CANS WERE HOT.
AT FIRST, I THOUGHT
THE REFRIGERATOR WAS BROKEN.
-A STAND-UP FRIDGE?
-THAT'S INTERESTING.
-YEAH.
-WAIT, IS THAT WHAT THAT IS?
Grossfeld: THAT'S WHAT THAT --
THESE ARE ALL HOT FRIDGES.
OH, MY GOSH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
FOR STORES.
THAT'S FOR A RETAIL STORE.
Herjavec:
DANNY, WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD?
IN THE TIME
YOU'VE BEEN DOING IT,
HOW LONG HAVE
YOU BEEN DOING IT,
-WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD?
-THIS IS -- YOU READY?
THIS IS SIX YEARS, AND CLOSE
TO $2 MILLION IN THE MAKING.
Sacca: WAIT, YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'VE SOLD $2 MILLION,
OR THERE'S $2 MILLION
GONE IN THE BUSINESS?
OH, NO, NO, NO.
$2 MILLION INVESTED
TO GET TO THIS POINT.
AND YOUR SALES ARE...?
I AM LAUNCHING THIS FALL.
IT TOOK THREE YEARS.
I WENT THROUGH OVER
1,500 DIFFERENT VARIATIONS.
I CAN'T TELL WHETHER YOU'RE
PITCHING OR ASKING FOR THERAPY.
I BELIEVE
THAT ALL THE ANSWERS TO BUSINESS
COME FROM GREEK MYTHOLOGY.
OH, NO.
AND SO, THERE IS A VERY FAMOUS
FIGURE IN GREEK MYTHOLOGY --
TO PUNISH A MAN
IN PERPETUITY...
[ LAUGHS ]
...WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT HE FINDS HIMSELF
PUSHING A ROCK UP A MOUNTAIN
ONLY TO GET IT TO THE TOP,
AND FINDS HIMSELF
BACK AT THE BOTTOM AGAIN.
THAT'S YOU.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-WHY IS THAT?
AND HOW IS THAT
GREEK MYTHOLOGY?
AFTER SIX YEARS,
YOU'VE JUST CONTINUED TO PUSH
THE HotShot UP THE MOUNTAIN,
AND NO SALES WHATSOEVER.
WELL,
HE HASN'T STARTED SELLING.
WE'RE LAUNCHING.
WHERE DID YOU GET
THE $2 MILLION?
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
I PUT A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
INTO IT, MY FATHER'S HELPED ME.
HOW DID YOU SPEND
$2 MILLION IN THAT TIME?
IT WAS CLOSE TO $1 MILLION
JUST IN DEVELOPMENT.
-DANNY, DEVELOPMENT OF WHAT?
-YEAH, WHAT WERE YOU DEVELOPING?
PEOPLE...?
DEVELOPING THE BEVERAGE
SO THAT IT CAN SIT
ON CONSTANT HEAT
FOR UP TO FOUR MONTHS.
THE FORMULA.
EVERYTHING HAD TO BE TESTED.
SO, DANNY, HAVE YOU HAD
ANY CONVENIENCE STORES SAY,
"THIS IS AMAZING.
WE WANT IT"?
I HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST,
BUT NOBODY'S READY TO GIVE ME
SOME BIG P.O.
THEY ALL WANT TO TEST IT.
BUT THEY'RE WILLING TO COMMIT
TO DO A TEST?
YES.
AS A MATTER OF FACT,
ONE OF THE ONES
THAT WERE MOST INTERESTED
WERE MOVIE THEATERS.
THEY HAVE A HUGE DEMAND
FOR COFFEE,
AND THEY CAN'T SATISFY IT.
I WISH SOMEBODY HERE OWNED
A MOVIE-THEATER CHAIN.
WHO COULD THAT BE?
JAPAN LAST YEAR,
HOT CANNED COFFEE
WAS A $15 BILLION
IN SALES.
WHAT?
I ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE
IT'S ONE OF THE LARGEST
BEVERAGE CATEGORIES
NOBODY'S EVER HEARD OF.
SIX YEARS WITH NO SALES
FOR AN ENTREPRENEUR
MAKES YOU START TO THINK,
"MAYBE I SHOULD TRY
SOMETHING ELSE."
I HAVE A RULE.
IF YOU CAN'T MAKE MONEY
IN 36 MONTHS,
YOU TAKE IT BEHIND THE BARN
AND YOU SHOOT IT,
'CAUSE IT'S A HOBBY.
IT'S NOT A BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
DANNY, AS YOU WERE TELLING
YOUR STORY, I'M THINKING,
"IF I REALLY WANTED A COFFEE,
WOULD I BUY THAT,
OR WOULD I KEEP DRIVING?"
AND PLUS, WHAT WE HAVE HERE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE IN JAPAN
IS LOTS OF 24-HOUR
COFFEE SHOPS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
YEAH, THANK YOU.
-AND DANNY.
-YES, SIR?
MY WIFE, CRYSTAL,
IS MY INVESTING PARTNER,
AND SHE GOT US
INTO A LITTLE DEAL
OF A COFFEE COMPANY
CALLED BLUE BOTTLE COFFEE
-A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
-HEARD OF IT.
IT'S NOW GONE ON TO BE
THE FASTEST-GROWING COFFEE BRAND
IN THE COUNTRY.
I FEEL IT'S COMPETITIVE,
AND SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
MARK AND LORI ARE LEFT.
DANNY,
I HAPPEN TO LOVE THE IDEA.
HATE THE BUSINESS.
BUT I LIKE YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO, EVEN THOUGH I'M GONNA SAY
I'M OUT ON THE DEAL,
ONCE YOU'RE SHIPPING,
IF YOU WANT TO PUT
ONE OF THE HOT COOLERS
INTO A LANDMARK THEATER,
WE'LL GIVE IT A TEST.
I WOULD LOVE TO.
HOW ABOUT THE STADIUM, TOO?
I THINK THAT'S A HOME FOR THAT.
[ LAUGHS ]
-DANNY!
-ONE STEP AT A TIME.
I'M SORRY.
I'LL TAKE THE LANDMARK.
THAT ROCK'S GONNA ROLL BACK DOWN
AND SQUISH YOU.
I'M BEING GREEDY, I KNOW.
THAT'S OKAY,
BUT YEAH, I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
WELL, YOU GOT A CUSTOMER,
NOT AN INVESTOR.
-ONE SHARK LEFT. LORI.
-LORI.
OH, MY GOSH.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, HONESTLY,
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY,
I FEEL LIKE SAYING
THERE NEEDS TO BE SIX OUTS.
AND THE REASON I SAY THAT
IS BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
SO MANY TIMES WHERE SOMEBODY
SINKS A TON OF MONEY
INTO SOMETHING,
AND IN MY GUT, I FEEL LIKE
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
AND YOU JUST KEEP PUTTING IN
MORE AND MORE MONEY,
AND I FEEL LIKE SAYING YOU GOT
TO STOP THE BLEEDING SOMEWHERE.
NOT ONLY AM I SAYING
I AM OUT,
BUT I'M SUGGESTING
THAT YOU BE OUT, AS WELL.
NAH!
NO, I CAN'T GIVE UP NOW.
I'M GONNA LAUNCH THIS FALL.
-IT'S JUST MY OPINION.
-DANNY, DANNY.
WHETHER THE OTHER SHARKS
AGREE OR NOT.
-WE'LL TALK, DANNY.
-THANKS.
♪♪
I'M A LITTLE UPSET THAT NOBODY
SAW THE POTENTIAL OF THIS,
BUT I'VE BEEN HAVING PEOPLE
TELLING ME
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK
FOR A LONG TIME,
AND THAT'S JUST FUEL FOR ME
TO MAKE IT WORK.
-SIX YEARS.
-KEVIN...
-MAN, HILL, ROCK.
-HE HAS A POINT.
-PUSHING THE ROCK.
Narrator: UP NEXT
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR WHO BELIEVES
THERE IS MONEY TO BE MADE
FROM THIN AIR.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME RYAN FRAYNE,
I'M FROM PORTLAND, OREGON,
AND MY COMPANY
IS WINDCATCHER TECHNOLOGY.
AND I'M HERE TODAY
SEEKING $200,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 8% OF MY COMPANY.
NOW, ANYONE WHO'S TRIED
INFLATING AN OBJECT LIKE THIS
KNOWS WHAT A HUGE PAIN
IT CAN BE.
THEY TAKE FOREVER TO INFLATE.
AND YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR MOUTH
ON A VALVE.
-[ CHUCKLES ]
-YOU CAN SEE HERE
THAT AFTER I'VE BLOWN INTO
THIS CONVENTIONAL VALVE TWICE,
THIS BAG IS HARDLY INFLATED.
BUT WINDCATCHER
CHANGES ALL THAT.
WITH JUST A SINGLE
BREATH OF AIR,
I WAS ABLE TO INFLATE
THIS ENTIRE SHARK,
AND THIS IS BECAUSE WINDCATCHER
IS A RADICALLY DIFFERENT
INFLATION TECHNOLOGY
THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO INFLATE AN OBJECT THIS SIZE
IN SECONDS WITHOUT USING
ANY POWER OR PUMPING.
WOW.
AND WE'VE ALREADY INTEGRATED
THIS TECHNOLOGY
INTO OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT,
THE AirPad 2,
WHICH, LIKE ALL OF OUR PRODUCTS,
INFLATES AND PACKS UP
IN SECONDS.
-THAT'S AMAZING.
-YEAH.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S SO EASY
TO INFLATE,
I ALSO DESIGNED IT TO FOLD UP
AND DOUBLE AS A SEAT.
SO, AS YOU CAN SEE,
YOU CAN ATTACH THESE STRAPS
AND USE IT AS BOTH A SEAT
OR A PAD.
AND SHARKS,
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
THE APPLICATIONS
FOR WINDCATCHER'S TECHNOLOGY
ARE ENDLESS.
SO, LET ME ASK YOU.
WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS READY TO HELP ME
BLOW AWAY THE COMPETITION?
RYAN, THAT WAS
REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
THANKS.
YOU'RE GONNA TELL US
HOW IT WORKS, RIGHT?
SO, WHAT'S HAPPENING IS,
AND THE REASON IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN AN ORDINARY VALVE,
IS BECAUSE WE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS PHENOMENON
CALLED ENTRAINMENT.
SO, IT'S ENTRAINING,
OR SUCKING IN,
THE SURROUNDING AIR.
SO, EACH TIME
I BLOW INTO THIS VALVE...
...IT'S ACTUALLY SUCKING IN
THE SURROUNDING AIR.
IT'S A STREAM OF FAST-MOVING,
LOW-PRESSURE AIR.
BRILLIANT.
SO, IT INFLATES 10 TIMES FASTER
THAN THE CONVENTIONAL VALVE.
WHAT PREMIUM DO I PAY
FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY
VERSUS ANY OTHER
AIR MATTRESS?
WE SELL OUR AirPad
FOR $99.95.
SO, ALL THAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
THAT IS FROM THE VALVE FORWARD.
OTHERWISE
IT'S A STANDARD AirPad.
EXCEPT WITH OUR ABILITY
TO FOLD IT UP INTO A SEAT.
SO, THEN, RYAN,
YOU HAVE A PATENT.
YES, IT'S A UTILITY PATENT.
ARE YOU AN ENGINEER?
NO, I DON'T HAVE A BACKGROUND
IN ENGINEERING.
I'VE JUST BEEN TRYING
TO INVENT STUFF FOR A LONG TIME,
AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS HAS BEEN MOST SUCCESSFUL.
ENTRAINMENT IS --
IS PRETTY FANCY STUFF
THAT HASN'T BEEN INTRODUCED
TO A CONSUMER MARKET BEFORE.
HOW'D YOU STUMBLE UPON THIS?
I THOUGHT OF THE IDEA
AFTER A TRIP TO MY FAMILY
AT THE BEACH,
AND WE WERE ALL INFLATING
THOSE TERRIBLE, YOU KNOW,
POOL RAFTS WITH THOSE
TINY, LITTLE VALVES.
AND WHEN I GOT HOME
FROM PORTLAND,
I DID A BUNCH OF RESEARCH.
AND SO, I WAS SITTING
ON THE FLOOR OF MY APARTMENT,
AND SO I BLEW INTO THIS BAG,
BUT THIS TIME
I LEFT A LITTLE SPACE
BETWEEN ME AND THE BAG,
AND IT INSTANTLY INFLATED.
AND I WENT, "HOLY CRAP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON,"
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I WENT ON GOOGLE,
AND WITH A BUNCH OF TRIAL
AND ERROR,
WAS ABLE TO FIGURE OUT THAT
IT WAS, IN FACT, ENTRAINMENT,
REFINED THE IDEA DOWN,
COME UP WITH THIS VALVE
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT MAKE UP WINDCATCHER.
-VERY INTERESTING.
-SO, HOW LONG YOU BEEN DOING IT?
MAY 2013 IS WHEN WE DID
OUR KICKSTARTER.
WHAT'S THE REVENUE TODAY?
WHAT'S THE SALES
OVER THAT TIME?
$165,000.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
DO YOU WANT TO BUILD A BUSINESS
AROUND A TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S PROPRIETARY,
AND ALL YOUR PRODUCTS
HAVE THIS WINDCATCHER
-INFLATION SCHEME TO IT.
-YEAH.
OR DO YOU WANT TO LICENSE IT
COUNTRY BY COUNTRY,
REGION BY REGION --
-BOTH?
-BOTH.
THERE ARE A TON OF PRODUCTS
THAT I WOULDN'T WANT TO MAKE,
LIKE MEDICAL PRODUCTS.
AN INFLATABLE DONUT FOR A WOMAN
AFTER SHE'S GIVEN BIRTH,
-YOU KNOW, THEY USE THOSE...
-YES.
...I WOULDN'T
WANT TO MAKE THAT
'CAUSE IT'S NOT GOOD
FOR THE WINDCATCHER BRAND.
BUT THERE'S STILL POTENTIAL.
THERE'S STILL LOTS
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR LICENSING.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL, BECAUSE WINDCATCHER'S
ABOUT TRAVEL AND OUTDOOR GEAR.
WE DON'T MAKE, YOU KNOW,
HEMORRHOID PILLOWS
AND ATTACH OUR NAME TO THAT.
Herjavec:
RYAN, BREAK IT DOWN FOR ME.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
WHAT ARE YOU SELLING IT
WHOLESALE,
IF YOU HAVE ANY WHOLESALE?
I DON'T WANT TO REVEAL
MY COSTS,
BUT I CAN TELL YOU
MY MARGINS ARE 60%,
AND THAT'S SELLING
TO RETAILERS.
HOW ARE WE SUPPOSED TO INVEST
IN YOUR BUSINESS
-IF YOU DON'T TELL US ANYTHING?
-YEAH.
I'M TELLING YOU
IT'S MARGINS OF 60%.
[ SCOFFS ]
SO, FIVE FIGURES,
SUBSTANTIAL REVENUE?
SIX FIGURES, SEVEN FIGURES?
WELL, IF IT WAS
A MILLION DOLLARS,
I WOULDN'T BE HERE.
I WOULD HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
OKAY.
SO, RYAN, YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
THE CHALLENGE
OF TRYING TO ROLL OUT
PHYSICAL INVENTORY,
BUILDING A BUSINESS.
IF THIS TECHNOLOGY HAS MERIT,
AND CLEARLY IT DOES,
I LOOK AT YOU,
YOU'RE THE ONLY GUY
IN THE BUSINESS.
A LITTLE BIT OF
A MAD SCIENTIST GUY.
OKAY, GOT IT.
BUT THERE ARE VERY BIG PLAYERS
IN THE AIR MATTRESS BUSINESS.
OH, YEAH.
AND ONE STRATEGY
IS YOU'RE GONNA DISRUPT
THEIR BUSINESS
BY STEALING ALL THEIR SHARE...
YEAH.
...THEY'RE NOT GONNA LOVE YOU
AS MUCH AS THEY COULD.
SURE.
THEY COULD LOVE YOU
A LOT MORE IF YOU SIMPLY SAID,
"I'M GONNA CHANGE
THE MARKET FOR YOU.
I'M GONNA GO TO THE BIGGEST GUY,
I'M GONNA LICENSE THIS.
I WANT 80 CENTS, 60 CENTS,
WHATEVER IT IS,"
AND THEN YOU JUST STAY
IN YOUR APARTMENT ON THE PHONE,
AND A CHECK COMES
EVERY MONTH.
THAT'S CRAZY BORING.
I MEAN,
WHY WOULD I WANT TO DO THAT
WHEN I CAN INVENT STUFF?
CHECKS IN THE MAIL
ARE CRAZY BORING?
YEAH.
ONCE YOU INVENT SOMETHING,
YOU DON'T WANT TO GIVE THAT UP
AND HAVE SOMEBODY SCREW UP
HOW THAT GETS DEPLOYED
OUT INTO THE WORLD.
BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S AN EITHER/OR.
-I THINK YOU CAN DO BOTH.
-I DON'T THINK SO, EITHER.
BUT I THINK YOU CAN DRIVE UP
THE ROYALTY SALES, EXACTLY,
-BY SELLING MORE.
-EXACTLY.
CLEARLY YOU'RE
A VERY INNOVATIVE GUY,
BUT BUILDING A BUSINESS
TO $10 MILLION, $20 MILLION,
$30 MILLION, $40 MILLION,
$50 MILLION,
IT'S A DIFFERENT SKILL SET.
MAYBE YOU HAVE IT,
MAYBE YOU DON'T. I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE A SINGLE GUY
IN THE BASEMENT RIGHT NOW.
SO, I'M GONNA STRUCTURE
AN OFFER TO YOU
THAT REFLECTS THAT RISK TO ME
AS AN INVESTOR, OKAY?
OKAY.
YOU NEED CAPITAL.
HOW MUCH DO YOU COVET
YOUR EQUITY?
EXTREMELY,
BECAUSE I REALLY DO BELIEVE
IT'S GONNA BE WORTH $50 MILLION
IN JUST THREE YEARS.
ALL RIGHT, SO I'M GONNA
STRUCTURE SOMETHING
THAT REDUCES
THE AMOUNT OF EQUITY I ASK FOR
-AND GETS YOUR CAPITAL.
-OKAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
AS VENTURE DEBT.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU
FOR 6% OF EVERYTHING YOU SELL
UNTIL YOU'VE RETURNED ME
$800,000, OKAY?
OKAY?
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I WOULD DO.
AND THEN IT GOES AWAY.
IT'S GONE.
AND I WANT 3% EQUITY
FOR PROVIDING THIS FACILITY.
YOU CAN COUNTER
IF YOU THINK THAT'S UNFAIR,
OR YOU MAY FIND A BETTER DEAL
AND GIVE UP MORE EQUITY.
-I DON'T KNOW.
-SURE.
SO, I'M QUADRUPLING THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT YOU GIVE ME,
AND IN EXCHANGE,
YOU'RE KEEPING 3% OF MY COMPANY?
IS THAT RIGHT?
-[ LAUGHS ]
-YOU HAVE NO MONEY,
AND MAYBE ONE OF THESE SHARKS
WILL GIVE YOU THE MONEY,
BUT YOU'RE GONNA GIVE UP
8% OF YOUR COMPANY FOR IT --
OR MORE.
SO, HERE'S MY CONCERN,
KEVIN.
I'M ASKING FOR THE $200,000
BECAUSE I NEED TO USE IT,
AND YOU WANT ME TO START
PAYING YOU BACK IMMEDIATELY
AT THIS 6% ROYALTY.
DO YOU THINK
MONEY'S FREE, RYAN?
DO YOU THINK I JUST GIVE IT AWAY
'CAUSE I DON'T CARE ABOUT IT?
NO, I HOPE NOT.
I'M ASKING FOR RETURN.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S UNFAIR?
I THINK IT'S UNFAIR
FOR YOU TO ASK FOR ME
TO GIVE IT BACK RIGHT AWAY.
I'M ASKING BECAUSE I PLAN ON
USING IT
AND INVESTING IT
IN THE COMPANY.
WHY DON'T YOU COUNTER ME
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD DO?
THIS SEEMS LIKE A GOOD TIME
FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
TO JUMP IN WITH AN OFFER.
♪♪
SO, I'M QUADRUPLING THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT YOU GIVE ME,
AND IN EXCHANGE,
YOU'RE KEEPING 3% OF MY COMPANY?
IS THAT RIGHT?
-[ LAUGHS ]
-YOU HAVE NO MONEY,
AND MAYBE ONE OF THESE SHARKS
WILL GIVE YOU THE MONEY,
BUT YOU'RE GONNA GIVE UP
8% OF YOUR COMPANY FOR IT --
OR MORE.
Sacca: THIS SEEMS LIKE
A GOOD TIME FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
TO JUMP IN WITH AN OFFER.
ALL RIGHT, RYAN,
I'LL GIVE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000.
OKAY.
BUT I WANT 15%.
OUCH.
THAT SOUNDS EXPENSIVE,
LORI.
WELL, I THINK YOU NEED
A LOT OF HELP.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE A ONE-MAN BAND.
YOU NEED TO BE MAKING
A LOT OF OTHER PRODUCTS
WITH THIS GREAT
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT'S WHAT
I'M REALLY GOOD AT,
BUT IT'S GONNA REQUIRE ME
TO BE THERE HELPING YOU
AND ALSO HELPING WITH THE SALES
AND GETTING INTO THE RETAIL.
I LOVE HOW YOU WRITE
ON YOUR HAND.
-I DO THAT, TOO.
-YEAH, IT'S HARD FOR ME TO --
[ Laughing ]
I WRITE ON MY HAND.
YEAH, THAT'S NOT --
THAT'S NOT STRANGE AT ALL.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL
NERVOUS AT ALL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Sacca: HEY, LORI, DO YOU HAVE
SOME ROOM IN YOUR DEAL?
BECAUSE I THINK
I COULD BRING
A COMPLEMENTARY
SET OF STRENGTHS TO THIS DEAL.
I'M VERY INTRIGUED
BY THE TECHNOLOGY.
I DO KNOW IT SOLVES
A REAL PAIN POINT.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU REALLY NEED HELP WITH
IS TELLING THE STORY
ABOUT THE NEXT DOZEN PRODUCTS.
WE HAVE TO DEVELOP
THE PROTOTYPES
THAT SHOW HOW MIGHT IT BE USED
IN A MEDICAL SETTING,
HOW MIGHT IT BE USED IN
A RECREATIONAL RAFTING SETTING
-AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
-RIGHT.
I WOULD LOVE TO COME IN
AND SEE PART OF THAT DEAL
IF IT'S AVAILABLE.
I WOULD BE WILLING
TO JOIN IN WITH YOU, CHRIS,
AS YOU TAKE THE LICENSING END
AND I TAKE THE CONSUMER END.
BUT FOR BOTH OF US TOGETHER,
WE WOULD NEED
A HIGHER EQUITY STAKE.
-I HEAR THAT.
-OUCH.
WE'D NEED A LITTLE HIGHER
PERCENTAGE.
BUT REMEMBER SOMETHING,
YOU NOW WOULD BE
A THREE-MAN BAND,
TWO BEING SHARKS,
WHICH THAT'S HUGE.
YOU JUST DON'T OWN
ANY OF YOUR COMPANY ANYMORE.
WHAT'S THE OFFER, THEN?
I'M HAPPY TO SPLIT IT WITH YOU.
20%.
-OUCH!
-FOR 200K.
-FOR 20%?
-OUCH.
I CAN'T --
I WOULDN'T DO THAT DEAL
BECAUSE WE'VE GOTTEN
GUARANTEED ROYALTY DEALS
THAT I TURNED DOWN
THAT WERE FOR OVER $2 MILLION
OF GUARANTEED ROYALTIES.
RYAN, I LOVE THE PRODUCT.
AND I LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT ODD.
ODD PEOPLE MAKE
GREAT THINGS, RIGHT?
THANKS.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $200,000 FOR 10%.
I LIKE THE FACT
YOU'RE BRINGING IT OUT TO MARKET
'CAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU GET
A BETTER LICENSING DEAL
LATER ON.
WELL, WE'LL DO THE 15%.
SO, $200,000 FOR 15%?
I'LL DO THAT DEAL.
NOW, IF YOU HAVE TO WRITE
THAT DOWN,
YOU'RE GONNA RUN
OUT OF HAND SPACE.
YEAH, I KNOW.
AND YOU'LL LEARN WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TRAVEL WITH PAPER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOURS IS $200,000 FOR 10%.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO ALSO INCLUDE
A $10 MILLION LINE OF CREDIT
FOR PURCHASING ORDERS
AT THE PRIME INTEREST RATE?
WHY DO YOU WANT TO GIVE UP
ALL THE EQUITY DAY ONE?
I'LL DROP MY ASK DOWN TO 2%
JUST TO KEEP IT INTERESTING.
YEP.
GET THAT PAPER OUT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000,
10%, BACK THE PURCHASE ORDERS.
WHAT IS THERE
TO THINK ABOUT?
BECAUSE I CAME IN HERE
WITH A VALUATION
THAT I BELIEVED WAS FAIR --
MORE THAN FAIR.
OKAY, SO RYAN,
IF I GIVE YOU $200,000 FOR 8%,
BACK UP YOUR PURCHASE ORDERS,
DONE DEAL, RIGHT?
IT SOUNDS LIKE
A REALLY GOOD DEAL.
OR IF I GIVE YOU 200K --
NO, IT'S EITHER YES OR NO 'CAUSE
THAT'S WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
-...WITH CHRIS FOR 8% --
-RYAN, IT'S WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
-IT IS.
-ACROSS THE BOARD.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
FOR 6.5%.
REALLY?
THE EQUITY'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO YOU.
YES.
LOOK, WHAT'S 1.5% TO ME
IF THIS THING GOES
TO WHERE YOU'RE GONNA GO?
IT WILL.
RYAN, I'LL DROP MY ASK
DOWN TO 1%.
I'LL GIVE YOU WHAT YOU NEED,
THE $200,000 --
RYAN, I GAVE YOU MORE
THAN YOU WERE ASKING FOR.
I'LL GIVE YOU --
JUST GIVE ME 1% OF THE COMPANY.
-I WANT TO HEAR THE ANSWER.
-I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000, 6.5%.
IT'S MORE THAN YOU CAME IN HERE
ASKING FOR.
COME ON, RYAN.
Greiner:
I JUST CHANGED MY DEAL.
LORI, LET HIM GET --
I'M GONNA DO --
NO, I'VE CHANGED MY DEAL.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $200,000
FOR 5%.
CHRIS ISN'T IN THE DEAL.
JUST ME.
BUT YOU NEED
TO JUST SAY YES NOW.
AND I'LL FUND
THE PURCHASE ORDERS.
JUST YOU AND ME.
-$200,000 FOR 5%.
-MM-HMM.
LEFT AT THE ALTAR.
[ LAUGHS ]
OKAY. LET'S DO IT.
OH, MY GOD.
-SORRY, CHRIS.
-GOOD FOR YOU, LORI.
FELLOW INVENTOR.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE GOT WORK TO DO.
-AWESOME.
-THANK YOU.
-CONGRATS.
-THANKS, GUYS. THANK YOU.
-THAT'S AWESOME.
-THANKS.
O'Leary: CHRIS, LORI JUST
THREW YOU UNDER A BUS.
SHE DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT YOU!
IT WENT TOO LOW.
I'M SORRY.
WELCOME
TO THE SHARK TANK.
Frayne: I'M DEFINITELY
STILL PROCESSING WHAT HAPPENED.
I'M STILL FREAKING OUT.
WITH THE DEAL I GOT TODAY
WITH LORI,
I BELIEVE IT'S GONNA ALLOW ME
TO MOVE WINDCATCHER
IN THE DIRECTION THAT I FEEL
THE COMPANY CAN GO.
Narrator: LAST SEASON,
LYDIA EVANS FAILED TO SECURE
A DEAL IN THE TANK
FOR HER LOOFAH SOAP COMPANY
S.W.A.G. ESSENTIALS.
THIS BAR ALLOWS A GUY
TO CLEANSE, EXFOLIATE,
AND DISINFECT
THE SURFACE OF HIS SKIN.
ARE YOU MAKING THIS
YOURSELF?
I MAKE IT FROM MY HOME.
OH, YOU MAKE IT
IN YOUR HOME?
FROM YOUR HOME?
I THINK IT'S REALLY A HOBBY
AT THIS POINT.
BUT I AM GONNA GIVE YOU
MY NUMBER.
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHEN I WILL BE SINGLE.
[ Chuckling ] OH, MY GOD.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
Evans: EVERYONE GOES
ON "SHARK TANK" WANTING A DEAL.
I DIDN'T WALK AWAY WITH A DEAL.
WHAT I DID GET
WAS A CRASH COURSE IN BUSINESS.
MORNING.
I TOOK THE ADVICE THAT
THE SHARKS GAVE ME TO HEART,
AND IT HAS CHANGED THE DIRECTION
OF MY BUSINESS DRAMATICALLY.
THE FIRST THING I DID
WAS RETHINK MY WEBSITE
BECAUSE OF ROBERT'S ADVICE.
I TOOK LORI'S ADVICE
AND EXPANDED MY PRODUCT LINE.
I ADDED THE S.W.A.G. BAR LITE
FOR THOSE WITH ACNE
AND THE GYNGERELLA BAR
FOR WOMEN.
BUT THE BIGGEST CHANGE
IS THAT I WAS ABLE TO TAKE
MY BUSINESS
OUT OF MY TWO-BEDROOM APARTMENT
INTO A 3,000-SQUARE-FOOT
PRODUCTION FACILITY.
THAT'S THE MAGIC TOUCH
RIGHT THERE.
WHEN I PITCHED, I ONLY HAD
ABOUT $54,000 IN SALES.
IN THE SIX MONTHS
SINCE APPEARING ON "SHARK TANK,"
I'VE DONE OVER $340,000
IN SALES.
I'M IN TALKS
WITH CVS AND RITE AID
AND HOPING TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH BIG-BOX STORES SOON.
THAT'S THE NEXT STEP.
WE NEED TO GET AT LEAST
ANOTHER 150 ORDERS OUT.
CAN WE DO IT, PLEASE?
YEAH!
MY "SHARK TANK" EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
OKAY, GUYS, LET'S GO AHEAD AND
GET THESE ON THE TRUCK HERE.
WHAT STARTED
AS A KITCHEN-TABLE EXPERIMENT
HAS NOW BECOME
A FULLY LEGITIMATE BUSINESS,
AND I CAN SEE THIS
BECOMING SOMETHING HUGE.
SO SHARKS, IF YOU LIKE
WHAT YOU SEE, CALL ME,
ESPECIALLY YOU, DAYMOND.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS
DESIGNED TO INSPIRE
THE NEXT GENERATION
OF ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MELISSA JAWAHARLAL.
AND I'M LAVANYA.
Both: WE ARE SISTERS
AND CO-FOUNDERS...
...OF S.T.E.M. CENTER USA.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
SEEKING $150,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
JUST HOW THE ABCs
ARE THE BASIS OF COMMUNICATION,
ENGINEERING AND TECHNOLOGY
ARE THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR MODERN LIFE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE OUR WORLD
WITHOUT CELLPHONES, CARS,
OR THE INTERNET?
WHILE WE'VE BECOME
MORE DEPENDENT ON TECHNOLOGY
EVERY DAY,
FEWER AND FEWER PEOPLE
SEEM TO HAVE
EVEN A BASIC UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THINGS WORK.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED
S.T.E.M. CENTER USA.
S.T.E.M. STANDS FOR
SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY,
ENGINEERING, AND MATH.
WE SET UP
A CREATIVITY CENTER
FOR STUDENTS FROM 5 YEARS OLD
ALL THE WAY UP TO COLLEGE
TO LEARN HOW TO DESIGN,
BUILD, AND PROGRAM.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY
TO EXCITE THE NEXT GENERATION
OF S.T.E.M. LEADERS
AND BRING A S.T.E.M. CENTER
TO A LOCATION NEAR YOU?
WOW, YOU'RE SO, LIKE,
RIGHT ON.
Greiner: SO IN SYNC.
SO YOU GUYS TALK
LIKE THAT NORMALLY?
YES, PRETTY MUCH.
WE DO.
WE ARE SISTERS.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
SURE. SO, I'M --
I JUST TURNED 21 YEARS OLD.
I'M GOING INTO MY SENIOR YEAR
AT U.C. BERKELEY,
AND I'M STUDYING
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING.
I AM --
JUST TURNED 23 YEARS OLD.
I GRADUATED WITH A FULL
SCHOLARSHIP FROM U.S.C.
STUDYING MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING.
DURING MY TIME AT U.S.C.,
I ALSO WORKED ON TWO CURRENTLY
ORBITING SATELLITES.
I SERVED AS A DESIGN LEAD.
AND PRIOR TO JOINING
THE CENTER FULL TIME,
I ALSO WORKED AT A DEFENSE --
MAJOR DEFENSE CONTRACTOR.
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT,
TELL US ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
SO, WE ARE A SUPPLEMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
OUR CREATIVITY CENTER
IS BASED IN POMONA, CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE 85 STUDENTS
AT OUR CENTER.
75 OF THOSE STUDENTS
ARE YEARLY MEMBERS.
FIVE OF THEM
PAY MONTHLY,
AND THE REST ARE INTRODUCTORY
SIX-WEEK STUDENTS.
HOW MUCH DO THEY PAY
ANNUALLY?
OUR ANNUAL MEMBERSHIPS
RANGE FROM $1,400 TO $1,800
DEPENDING ON THE CLASSES.
DANG, $1,400?
FOR A YEARLY MEMBERSHIP.
WHAT'S THE MONTHLY?
THEY PAY AN AVERAGE OF $135
ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
IN ADDITION, WE ALSO OFFER
AFTER-SCHOOL PROGRAMS
TO LOCAL SCHOOLS.
WHAT'S REVENUE GONNA BE
THIS YEAR?
WE HAD $300,000 IN REVENUE
LAST YEAR.
THIS WAS BROKEN
INTO TWO REVENUE STREAMS.
WE HAVE OUR CREATIVITY CENTER.
THIS BROUGHT IN $130,000.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, AS WE
WERE WORKING WITH STUDENTS,
WE IDENTIFIED GAPS IN THE MARKET
FOR ROBOTICS TOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY,
WE CREATED A ROBOTIC PRODUCT
FOR UPPER MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
IS THAT THE BOX THERE?
WE RAN KICKSTARTER CAMPAIGNS --
CORRECT --
THAT BROUGHT IN
$170,000 IN SALES.
I ACTUALLY REMEMBER THIS
FROM KICKSTARTER.
-IT WAS REALLY SUCCESSFUL.
-YOU DO?
Sacca: WELL,
I'M A KICKSTARTER INVESTOR,
SO I PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION
TO THE STUFF
THAT INFLECTS THERE,
AND THIS GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION.
LOOK, I'M LOOKING AT THIS THING
WITH A LOT OF MOVING PARTS,
A LOT OF SPOKES ON IT,
AND I DON'T THINK
THE WHEEL'S TURNING YET
IN FULL CIRCLE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY,
AND I DON'T REALLY SEE WHAT
DIRECTION YOU'RE GONNA GO YET.
I WOULD'VE PREFERRED IF THIS
HAD BEEN A LITTLE MORE GELLED
SO THAT I COULD'VE SEEN
SOMETHING
I COULD JUST POUR
MY GASOLINE ONTO
IN THE FORM OF CAPITAL
TO EXPAND IT.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE THERE YET.
I THINK IT'S WAY TOO EARLY FOR
AN INVESTOR, AT LEAST FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MR. WONDERFUL,
FOR YOUR THOUGHTS.
LOOK, IT MAY NOT MATTER TO THIS
SOULLESS CAPITALIST OVER HERE,
BUT I'M RAISING A COUPLE OF
GIRLS, AND, YOU KNOW,
I'M IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S JUST DOMINATED BY MEN.
THE TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
IS COMPLETELY DEVOID OF WOMEN.
AND SO, I'M CURIOUS.
I GET A HINT THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING REALLY DEEPLY
MISSION-DRIVEN
BEHIND YOU GUYS.
WE ARE HUGE NERDS,
AND WE ARE NERDS
THAT WANT TO SHARE THAT PASSION
WITH OTHER STUDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY FOR GIRLS --
YOUNG GIRLS THAT GET TOLD
BEING NERDY ISN'T COOL,
WE WANT TO CHANGE THAT,
AND THAT STARTS FROM THE BOTTOM.
MELISSA, YOU -- YOU GUYS
ARE INCREDIBLY POLISHED,
BUT I SEE A LOT OF WORK,
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S AS EASY
TO SCALE AS, UH...
AS I WISH IT WAS.
LOOK, I'M EXCITED
ABOUT YOU GUYS.
I'M NOT AS EXCITED
ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban:
GUYS, YOU WANT TO GROW,
AND YOU HAVE
THIS MAGNIFICENT GOAL.
BUT YOU'RE -- YOU'RE A LITTLE
BIT TOO OPEN-ENDED FOR ME.
I THINK TAKING THOSE FIRST STEPS
ARE GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT
AND REQUIRE
A LOT OF HAND-HOLDING.
I STILL THINK
YOU'LL BE SUCCESSFUL.
I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT FIT FOR ME,
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MR. CUBAN.
YOU STILL HAVE TWO SHARKS.
YOU'VE GOT LORI
AND YOU'VE GOT CHRIS.
FOR ME, I THINK
A LOT OF THE CHALLENGES HERE
REALLY GO BACK
TO VALUATION,
BECAUSE THIS IS A BUSINESS
THAT DOESN'T HAVE
THE TRADITIONAL SCALE
OF A TECH COMPANY.
THAT SAID, I DEEPLY
BELIEVE IN YOUR MISSION.
I THINK SCHOOLS ARE GONNA
START WAKING UP AND REALIZING
THEY NEED MORE OF THIS
IN THE SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE GONNA BE
REACHING OUT TO YOU.
THERE IS A BIG THIRST
FOR MATERIALS LIKE THIS.
SO, WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS OFFER YOU 150K
FOR 25% OF THE COMPANY.
I DO HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT
FOR THAT OFFER
AND WE DO APPRECIATE IT,
AND WE WOULD LOVE
TO CONSIDER IT.
WE DO BELIEVE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOW. [ LAUGHS ]
MELISSA, DO YOU NEED
TO CONSIDER IT?
WE DO BELIEVE THAT
A $1 MILLION VALUATION IS FAIR.
SO, HOW DO I GET
THAT MONEY BACK, THEN?
WHEN IS THIS THING -- YOU KNOW,
ARE YOU GONNA SELL THIS?
DOES IT GET BOUGHT BY --
BY SOME MASSIVE CONGLOMERATE?
I MEAN, WHERE DO WE GET
THAT MONEY BACK?
SO, OUR PROJECTIONS
FOR THIS YEAR IS $450,000.
FOR OUR 2016 PROJECTION,
WE ARE LOOKING
AT $3.2 MILLION IN SALES.
SO, IF YOU'RE INVESTING
$150,000 FOR 25%,
YOU WANT YOUR $150,000 BACK
WITHIN A YEAR OR TWO.
-AND SO, IF YOU --
-NOT NECESSARILY.
I MEAN, I'VE OWNED TWITTER STOCK
SINCE 2007
AND IT TURNS OUT IT'S GONE UP
A LOT SINCE I INVESTED.
I'VE OWNED UBER STOCK
SINCE 2009.
THAT'S GONE UP A LOT.
I DON'T NEED MY MONEY BACK
IN A YEAR AND A HALF.
I HAVE THE MONEY TO SPARE.
THAT SAID, I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE TERMINAL EVENT IS
FOR THIS COMPANY.
I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE EXIT IS.
THERE ARE CERTAIN FOUNDERS
WHO WILL NEVER SELL,
AND AS AN EQUITY INVESTOR,
THAT'S A BUMMER
BECAUSE I WANT TO GET
THAT MONEY BACK
AND MORE AT SOME POINT.
OUR VISION
IN TERMS OF THE BUSINESS ITSELF
IS TO HAVE A S.T.E.M. CENTER
IN EVERY CITY.
AS WE GROW,
IF WE ARE ABLE TO FIND SOMEONE
WHO'S INTERESTED
TO TAKE THAT FORWARD,
ABSOLUTELY
WE WOULD BE INTERESTED.
Herjavec: MELISSA, DO YOU HAVE
A COUNTER FOR CHRIS?
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SHARE.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
CHRIS HAS MADE AN OFFER,
BUT LORI MAY ALSO BE INTERESTED
IN MELISSA AND LAVANYA'S
SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY,
ENGINEERING, AND MATH
EDUCATION COMPANY,
S.T.E.M. CENTER USA.
Herjavec: MELISSA, DO YOU HAVE
A COUNTER FOR CHRIS?
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SHARE.
HERE'S THE THING.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR A COUNTER
BECAUSE I LOVE LORI,
AND I HAVE DEEP RESPECT FOR HER
QVC AND RETAIL CONNECTIONS,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
AND SO, I THINK I HAVE
A UNIQUE SKILL SET
TO BRING TO THE TABLE
WITH YOU GUYS,
AND SO I'D LOVE TO HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE COMING BACK WITH.
-I JUST WANT TO SHARE SOMETHING.
-OH, COME ON.
A PERSONAL ANECDOTE ABOUT
WHAT S.T.E.M. MEANS TO YOU?
-'CAUSE I WOULD LISTEN TO THAT.
-[ LAUGHS ]
I'D LISTEN TO THAT.
ABOUT A ROBOT YOU BUILT
WHEN YOU WERE 8 YEARS OLD?
-I WOULD TOTALLY HEAR THAT OUT.
-JUST LIKE KEVIN...
-OH, MY GOODNESS.
-COME ON.
JUST LIKE KEVIN,
I'M PART OF A VERY EXCLUSIVE
AND PRESTIGIOUS CLUB.
I'M A WOMAN.
I SEE IN YOU GUYS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK
IS REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
TO WOMEN.
I THINK BOTH OF YOU
ARE EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE.
I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
I LIKE THE CONCEPT,
AND I LIKE WHAT IT WILL DO
FOR YOUNG WOMEN.
SO, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER,
BECAUSE I THINK
THE THREE OF US TOGETHER
WILL BE VERY, VERY SUCCESSFUL.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
$150,000 FOR 20%.
THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MS. GREINER.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO GET AN OFFER
FROM YOU, AS WELL.
WE ARE HERE
TO GROW OUR BUSINESS, AND --
WHAT PROBLEM
ARE YOU TRYING TO SOLVE?
WHAT DO YOU NEED
FROM A SHARK?
WE NEED ASSISTANCE
IN EXPANDING THE CENTER
THROUGH FRANCHISE,
AND WE NEED
THAT CAPITAL INVESTMENT
TO DO THE DOCUMENTATION
TO TAKE THIS TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
THAT'S WHAT'S RESTRICTING US
FROM DUPLICATING CURRENTLY.
SO, WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR YOU SAY
IS, "I NEED A SPOT ON QVC.
I NEED AN INFOMERCIAL.
I NEED AN END CAP
AT A BED, BATH & BEYOND."
THAT'S NOT ALL THAT I DO.
THAT'S CRAZY.
YOU GUYS KNOW THAT.
YOU'VE DONE YOUR HOMEWORK.
Melissa: BOTH OF YOU OFFER
A LOT OF WONDERFUL THINGS.
WE HAVE A PRODUCT LINE,
WE HAVE A CENTER.
WE ARE WORKING TO EXPAND BOTH,
AND I KNOW THAT BOTH OF YOU
CAN HELP US WITH THAT.
WHAT WE'D LOVE TO DO
IS WORK WITH BOTH OF YOU.
I'M WILLING TO SHARE BECAUSE
I SEE MERIT TO BOTH OF US.
I SEE
WHERE I CAN TAKE IT,
BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT CHRIS CAN BRING MERIT.
IF CHRIS IS WILLING
TO ACCEPT MY HAND BACK IN.
LOOK,
YOU'RE WILLING TO SHARE
BECAUSE YOU'RE SWIMMING
IN MY WAKE.
NO.
YOU'RE RIDING MY COATTAILS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN BRING.
THAT'S NOT WHY
I'M WILLING TO SHARE.
IT'S FREE MONEY FOR LORI.
AND SO THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE WILLING TO SHARE.
OH, WOW, WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK THE EQUITY'S
GONNA BE WORTH MONEY.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SHARE IT.
I WANT IT TO BE WORTH MY TIME.
AND SO I WANT TO HAVE
A BIG ENOUGH COMMITMENT
TO THE COMPANY
THAT WHEN YOU GUYS CALL,
I GET THAT MUCH MORE EXCITED
WHEN WE ULTIMATELY DO SELL THIS
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS.
I WANT TO HAVE SOME SKIN
IN THE GAME.
I WANT TO OWN
A LOT MORE OF THIS COMPANY.
MY OFFER, I'LL REPEAT --
IT'S $150,000 AT 20%,
AND I'LL BE THERE WITH YOU SIDE
BY SIDE EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
CHRIS, WHAT WAS YOUR
FINAL OFFER?
I'LL COME DOWN TO 150K
FOR 22.5%.
WOULD EITHER OF YOU DO
$200,000 FOR 20%?
I WOULD.
LORI, WE'D LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU.
WE'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU,
LORI.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. SACCA.
-WHOA.
-OKAY, CHEERS.
♪♪
-THANK YOU, LORI.
-YOU ARE DYNAMOS.
-YOU CAN DO ANYTHING.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-YEAH, THANK YOU.
-GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
-THANK YOU, SHARKS.
-THANK YOU, EVERYONE.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
SO, LORI, YOU'RE REALLY
STICKING IT TO CHRIS.
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, I'M NOT.
Melissa:
WE DIDN'T TAKE CHRIS' OFFER
BECAUSE LORI
GAVE US AN OFFER
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO HESITATION
AND 200% BELIEF IN WHAT WE DO.
TO WORK WITH A FEMALE
LIKE LORI,
WHO IS SUCH
A STRONG ROLE MODEL --
IN TECH, IN SALES,
IN EVERYTHING -- IS A DREAM.